SHOOTS AND A GLOVE SAVE, HALAK,
SHORTHANDED BID BY
SCORE AND IT'S CHIASSON IN
>> Matt: NUMBER 8 OF THE SEASON
FOR CHIASSON.
IT COMES ON THE POWER PLA OUT.
SCHMALTZ HAS IT.
WRISTER UP HIGH.
BUT A GLOVE SAVEAT WHAT HE
SEES, HE SEES THE SHOT
COMPLETELY.
BOYD HAS TO GET IN LUKE
SCHENN TO THE SHOT.
AND A STOP BYRAPAROUND
AND IT'S HORVAT AND IT'S 2- THEE
YOU WERE THE STICK BETWEEN THE
PADS.
AND T T
HORVAT SCORES AND IT'S 3-0.
BO HORVAT.
THEY BURIES ANOTHER ONE HERE
TONIGHT THE CAPTAIN LEADING THE.
>> Tyson: HOLY.
WHAT MOVEMENT  SHOT.
AND THEY JUST WALK RIGHT IN TO
ANOTHER ONEROSS THE
GOAL LEAN AND THE COYOTES ARE
OFF AND RUNNING AND IT ALL HALA.
THEY SCORE IT'S POKED SHIN
PAD OF THE CANUCKS PLAYER. THE .
[ BOOING ]
>> Matt: THE FANS DON'T LIKE IT,
BUT IT' AND WHAT A SET UP FRONTE
IT RIGHT THROUGH.
AND IT.
HIS CAN.
LIGHTT IT.
SHEERAN OPPORTUNITY,THAT HIT A I
BE
DIRECTION.
AGARLAND.
OFF THE PIPE.
>> Tyson: THEY ARE LOOKING FOR
MORE. HALAK.
>> Tyson: NICE DIRTY FRONT.
STOPPED.
HALAK A BIG POINT BLANKER ELIAS
PETTERSSON COMES IN AND HE'S
STOP
BUREAUS.
TRIED TO GET A PASS AND THAT